à l'heure où le quartier dort encore ces
dames s'affairent autour du repas de
noël et c'est de bon là dedans madame
alors dedans il ya des pâtes des
haricots verts des carottes des pommes
de terre et puis de la dinde
voilà un petit curry coco cuba elles
sont voisines soeur ou cousines et
depuis quelques années elles consacrent
leur matin de noël où son domicile fixe
de fort de france et du lamentin 120
repas complet protéines sucres lents
vitamines pour des ventes rafa m savon
ou la mère noël alors ce matin oui pour
les défavorisés oui vous faites c'est en
toute discrétion toute discrétion
je fais ça pour eux avec l'acteur toute
l'année ces bénévoles donnent un coup de
main à l'association le fourneau en
centre-ville alors noël c'était une
évidence
ils sont contents parce qu'ils ont mangé
en fait depuis hier à 10 heures
sinon ils n'ont rien mangé hier soir
jusque là ce matin l'équipe sait très
bien d'où se rendre à s'il est là il est
cochée jules à 56 ans si un bon jour
ja pas vous offrir un plat et un petit
poisson voilà il vit sous le pont de la
rocade
depuis deux ans personne ne sait
vraiment pourquoi ce monsieur est 100
foyers câblés sens bien
lannoy de 7 à 4 pourquoi les gens sont
dans la rue vous dise par lydie sipa en
général sont pas envie de dire principe
ouais mais vous êtes toujours bien
accueillis oui toujours toujours avec
eux à gauche il y en a un qui marche là
il ya quatre ans l'équipe a commencé à
tourner avec 80 repas aujourd'hui 122
suffiront sans doute pareil il ya de
nouveaux venus comme ce jeune près de
l'atrium
je me dis personnellement
c'est un peu compliqué mais ça peut
arriver à tout le monde d'être dans la
rue donc
monde il a alors qu'il faut aussi
s'aider mutuellement c'est leur donner
la force de continuer à vivre quand tu
vois que les gens qui n'ont pas de
famille et couchent dans la rue comme ça
et c'est triste mais en même temps quand
je fais le repas je fais le voit que
c'est ça me fait plaisir aujourd'hui
comme toute l'année les bénévoles mesure
bien l'utilité de leur action et c'est
pas vraiment la wii le s'héberger mais
son projet par tous les moyens mais
cuisine et de quoi manger
donc voilà je me débrouille avec ce que
je peux et cette dame là ce matin c'est
une bonne surprise cela fait les voilà
elle a fait ça bea
tout à fait et l'initiative n'est pas
isolé distribution de café chaud
couverture ou sandales beaucoup de
bénévoles sont venus tendre la main ce
matin aux plus démunis